salut les épis curieuse et les épis
curieux à banos il ya plus de batterie
je suis sûr que ça vous arrive et c'est
pas à cause du froid allez on va se
mettre au chaud je vais vous expliquer
comment elle fonctionne et comment les
faire durer plus longtemps c'est
vraiment là
[Musique]
il fait meilleur ici et je vais en
profiter pour faire le plein alors le
principe de base de fonctionnement nos
batteries elle n'a rien de nouveau on
provoque une réaction chimique entre
deux métaux pour créer un courant
électrique on doit ce procédé alessandro
volta un scientifique italien qui a
assemblé la première pile en 1800 son
invention a été baptisée ainsi parce
qu'il s'agissait d'un empilement comme
ici de rondelles de cuivre et de
rondelles de zinc séparés par des
tampons imbibés d'eau salée le zinc est
un métal qui a tendance à perdre des
électrons alors que le cuivre est un
métal qui lui a tendance à gagner des
électeurs ils forment des ions c'est à
dire des atomes qui portent décharge
électrique l'eau salée est un
électrolyte un liquide dans lequel
peuvent circuler ces ions quand on relit
les deux extrémités de la pile le pôle
négatif le pôle positif par un fil
conducteur on permet aux électrons de
circuler du moins vers le plus c'est ce
qu'on appelle un courant électrique le
problème des piles de première
génération c'est que le phénomène n'est
pas réversible quand ou le zinc est
oxydé
la pile est bon à jeter pas n'importe où
aujourd'hui dans nos batteries de
téléphone on utilise des ions lithium un
métal qui a un potentiel réducteur
quatre fois plus important que le zinc
c'est l'élément chimique qui partage le
plus ces électrons
il a bon coeur ce lithium île à l'autre
avantage d'être le métal le plus léger
ce qui nous permet d'avoir des
téléphones qui pèse aux alentours de 150
grammes équipés de batteries qui
fournissent de l'énergie pendant près de
24 heures le courant se produit il grâce
à la circulation lyon lithium entre les
deux électrodes au sein de plus cellules
comme celle ci on ne parle plus de piles
mais d'accumulateurs parce que cette
fois la réaction chimique est réversible
pendant qu'on utilise la batterie les
ions lithium migrent vers la cathode qui
est souvent formés là mélange de lithium
et d'autres métaux et quand on branche
notre téléphone pour le recharger le
courant renvoie les ions lithium vers la
note en graphite où ils sont stockés
ce passage des ions d'une électrode à
l'autre représente ce que l'on appelle
un cycle de charge une batterie ne peut
supporter qu'un nombre de cycles limité
avec les technologies actuelles
on est au minimum à 2000 charge soit une
durée de vie d'environ 10 ans en
fonction de l'utilisation de l'appareil
il n'est donc pas nécessaire de changer
son téléphone tous les deux ans j'ai
d'ailleurs fait une vidéo à ce sujet
dans laquelle explique également comment
nos téléphones portables sont recyclés
elle se trouve ici dans le petit plus
dur est dû à plusieurs raisons au fur et
à mesure des charges et des décharges
des dépôts se forment à l'intérieur de
la batterie et les électrodes se déforme
les ions lithium s'échange donc de moins
en moins bien et ils finissent par ne
plus circuler du tout la manière dont
nous utilisons nos téléphones peut
accélérer cette dégradation il y a deux
phases pendant lesquels la batterie se
détériore le plus dont la charge est
comprise entre 0 et 20% et quand elle
est comprise entre 80 et 100% premier
conseil donc pour prolonger la durée de
vos batteries ferrand sort que la charge
soit le plus souvent comprise entre 20
et 80 % ce qui correspond à la zone de
fonctionnement optimal très concrètement
n'attendez pas qu'elles sont
complètement vide pour la recharger et
al'inverse ne laissez pas votre
téléphone branché en permanence
évitez de laisser brancher toute la nuit
par exemple c'est plus facile à dire
qu'à faire s'il faut se relever en
pleine nuit pour débrancher son
téléphone je sais à l'est autre conseil
privilégiez les chargeurs du fabricant
ils coupent automatiquement le courant
quand la batterie est chargée à 100%
on habille une batterie produit de
l'électricité grâce à une réaction
chimique et comme beaucoup de réactions
chimiques elle est influencée par la
température quand il fait très froid la
batterie est un peu comme une aile et
engourdi les ions lithium circule de
plus en plus lentement entre les
électrodes donc contrairement à ce qu'on
entend souvent le froid ne décharge pas
la batterie plus vite puisque lésions ne
circulent plus vers la cathode jupe en
fout hein j'ai vu la jauge diminuer sous
mes yeux non tu n'es pas fou le froid
ralentit parfois tellement la
circulation des ions dans la batterie
que celle-ci ne produit plus assez de
courant téléphone pense que la batterie
est à plat alors qu'elle est juste en
train hiberner c'est un malentendu par
conséquent pas besoin de la branche est
tout de suite attendez que le téléphone
se réchauffe un peu à température
ambiante pour voir si la jauge remonte
pour faire durer la batterie plus
longtemps je lui ai fait une petite
bouillotte ou à la très mauvaise idée
elles craignent aussi le show la chaleur
accélère la réaction chimique qui a lieu
dans la batterie est aussi des formes et
les électrodes de façon irréversible
tout cela empêche les ions de se fixer
correctement et diminue la capacité de
stockage d'énergie une surchauffe trop
importante peut même entraîner des
réactions chimiques qui peuvent aller
jusqu'à l'explosion de la batterie
tu aurais pu dire avant non les
batteries lithium-ion sont dans le
commerce depuis 1991 et la technologie
n'a cessé de s'améliorer grâce aux
recherches sur les nouveaux matériaux
tenait pendant les 20 dernières années
leur capacité à doubler bon en même
temps la consommation électrique de nos
smartphones augmente tout aussi vite
alors sur quelle piste de travail les
chercheurs et les ingénieurs pour
améliorer leurs capacités et leur durée
de vie eh bien ils essaient de changer
les ingrédients en remplaçant
l'électronique liquide par des solides
qui résisterait mieux à la chaleur ou en
remplaçant le lithium par du sodium mais
bon pour le moment ils n'ont pas encore
trouvé la bonne recette pour que nos
batteries dure plus longtemps dans la
journée les ingénieurs essaie d'intégrer
des panneaux solaires dans les écrans
des téléphones ou de mini générateurs
capable de transformer les mouvements du
téléphone en électricité tu veux dire
qu'il va se recharger en bougeant un
jour peut-être pendant que mon téléphone
fini de se charger si cette vidéo vous a
plu n'hésitez pas à liker et à vous
abonner à la chaîne ah c'est bon je suis
recharger enfin ma batterie est
rechargée à 80% je vais pouvoir repartir
à l'aventuré
aller à dans deux semaines les épis
curieuse et les épis curieux
alors pourquoi la faune dufetel défilent
et bien j'y réponds et encore plus de
questions dans ce petit livre réalisé en
partenariat avec nathan vous y
retrouverez également un quiz est un
test pour savoir quel fromage vous êtes
personnellement je suis roquefort
avis aux fondus de lecture le lien est
ici
[Applaudissements]